Qui a vaincu le djihad mondial ? L'armée américaine,
les soldats américains, avec leurs alliés,
qui ont combattu sur des champs de bataille éloignés.
Et peut-être que viendra un temps où on leur donnera la reconnaissance qu'ils méritent vraiment.
Tous ces facteurs, et bien d'autres encore,
certains que l'on ne comprend pas encore très bien,
tous combinés, ont permis
de vaincre une monstruosité aussi immense que le Ben Ladenisme,
le djihad mondial, cela nécessitait cet effort de groupe.
Maintenant, tous ces facteurs ne marcheront pas pour le djihad local.
L'armée américaine ne va pas investir le Nigéria
pour renverser Boko Haram,
et il est peu probable que l'équipe 6 du SEAL descende en rappel
dans les maisons des chefs d'Al Shabaab pour les expulser.
Mais beaucoup des autres facteurs qui étaient en jeu
sont aujourd'hui encore plus forts qu'avant. La moitié du travail est déjà fait.
Nous n'avons pas à réinventer la poudre.
La notion d'un djihad violent, dans lequel plus de musulmans sont tués
que dans n'importe quelle autre communauté est déjà profondément discréditée.
Nous n'avons pas à y revenir.
Les chaînes satellites et Internet informent
et donnent du pouvoir aux jeunes musulmans par de nouveaux moyens enthousiasmants.
Et le Printemps Arabe a permis la mise en place de gouvernements,
pour la plupart des gouvernements islamistes,
qui savent que, pour leur propre durabilité,
ils doivent accepter des extrémistes en leur sein.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de les persuader, mais nous devons les aider
car ils n'ont jamais été dans cette situation auparavant.
La bonne nouvelle, encore, c'est que la plupart des choses dont ils ont besoin
nous les avons déjà, et nous savons très bien les distribuer :
une assistance économique, pas seulement de l'argent, mais une expertise,
la technologie, le savoir-faire,
des investissements privés, des conditions équitables de commerce,
la médecine, l'éducation, les supports techniques pour que la formation
de leurs forces de police devienne plus efficace,
pour que leurs forces antiterroristes le soient aussi.
Nous avons tout ça en abondance.
Pour certaines autres de leurs nécessités
nous ne savons pas bien les distribuer. Peut-être que personne ne l'est vraiment.
Du temps, de la patience, de la subtilité, de la compréhension --
ça, c'est plus dur à donner.
Aujourd'hui, je vis à New York. Cette semaine,
des posters sont apparus dans le métro new-yorkais
décrivant le djihad comme sauvage.
Mais pendant toutes ces années où j'ai couvert le Moyen Orient,
je n'ai jamais été aussi optimiste qu'aujourd'hui
quant au fait que le fossé entre le monde musulman et l'Occident
est en train de rétrécir rapidement,
et une des nombreuses raisons de mon optimisme
c'est que je sais qu'il y a des millions,
des centaines de millions de gens, des musulmans comme ce vieil imam
de Tunis, qui veulent reconquérir ce mot
et restaurer son sens admirable et originel.
Ben Laden est mort. Le Ben Ladenisme a été vaincu.
Sa définition du djihad peut maintenant être effacée.
A ce djihad nous pouvons dire : "A jamais. Bon débarras."
Au vrai djihad nous pouvons dire : "Bon retour. Bonne chance."
Merci. (Applaudissements)